bei uns ist ja nun ich habe einen
Campingplatz damit die Anfragen ich war
jetzt in den Medien vor einer Woche erst
gewesen und diese Gespräch war wirklich
bloß eine Minute und ich bin erstaunt
und erschrocken wie doch jetzt die Welle
geschlagen wird und ich jetzt seitdem
wirklich täglich Anfragen bekomme also
vorher hatte ich es auch schon aber
nicht in diesen Dimensionen wie jetzt
anfragen bekomme ich täglich von
Menschen die
Camp Dauercamper werden wollen mit
Erstwohnsitz weil sie eben ihre Miete
nicht mehr zahlen können oder
beziehungsweise anders die wissen nicht
mehr wie es weitergeht das Problem ist
die Medien sind voll von Panik Gas Strom
mieten
alles wird teurer
die Rentner werden vergessen zum
Beispiel da geht es doch weiter und wie
und jetzt kommt es noch normalerweise
sind sie zu zweit einer stirbt das ist
nur noch einer da jetzt müssen sie aber
die Miete trotzdem bezahlen mit einer
Rente das ist nicht mehr möglich und
jetzt so kommen die zu mir und dann
kriegen die in den Fragen nach und
Kriegen Dauercampingplatz haben eine
Anschaffung von Wohnwagen oder im Modul
oder wie auch immer aber zumindest eine
Campingmöglichkeit die haben sie die
können ja einen Raten abzahlen das ist
wie eine Miete und haben eine
Dauercamping eine Dauerplatz von 1000
Euro
je nachdem wie groß der ist also ab 700
bis aufwärts kein Problem wie teuer ist
ein Dauercampingplatz für ein Jahr bei
Ihnen also der kostet bei uns ab 700
Euro für eine genau ist eine Parzelle
und dann geht es also man kann sagen
sieben bis 1000 Euro ist so der normale
Schnitt für ein ganzes Jahr wie teuer
ist es monatlich wenn man jetzt bei
ihnen lebt als erstes
beginnt dann entweder so um die 30 40
500 ja um die 60 Euro vielleicht im
Monat da muss man den Camper natürlich
auch noch abstottern die man kaufen
genau das ist aber dann aber in dem
Moment wenn ich monatlich meine Miete
bezahle nehme ich doch meine monatliche
Miete und bezahle davon meinen
Campingplatz also mein mein Camper den
ich mir dann nehme und habe den dann
auch in so und so viel Zeit bezahlt und
ist erledigt wie viele wohnen jetzt
schon bei Ihnen mit Ärzten
auf den wenn ich jetzt wir haben ja nun
zwei Campingplätze wir haben angefangen
mit sechs das war vor Corona
und während Corona haben wir auf dem
einen 18
Dauercamper mit erstwohnsitzen die auch
wirklich gekommen sind aufgrund der
Presse und den Umständen so wie es jetzt
ist und jetzt
geht das immer mehr in diese Richtung
finanzielle Sache und die andere und der
andere der hat schon 20 dauerkämpfer die
mit den ersten und sitzt also das war
früher nicht
also ja vorher war das Camping
touristisch das war wie wie meine Villa
mein Wochenendgrundstück da fahre ich
dorthin und mache meinen Urlaub oder
mache Urlaub und fahre dort machen mein
Garten und
Campingplätze dann wieder nach Hause
aber jetzt eben nicht mehr jetzt bleiben
die dort und werden auch nicht mehr als
ich eine Miete nehmen also das ist jetzt
einfach mal die Zeit ist extrem es ist
erschreckend werden eben diesen sehr
spannenden Punkt dass man noch nicht
sagen kann dass es jetzt schon ein Meet
liegt sondern auch vor allem an der
Panik genau die Menschen jetzt schon
sparen wollen weil sie Angst haben also
ich lebe ja nun auf dem Campingplatz
mehr oder weniger und habe auch sehr
engen Kontakt zu all den Campern die wir
haben und diese
Existenzängste was ist mit dem Euro wie
das ist ja aber da ist ja nicht nur die
Camper es redet ja jeder wie lange ist
ja noch wenn ich mir überlege was wir an
Geld der Staat Deutschland an Geld
rausgibt ob das eben die Flüchtlinge
sind wir geben
also alles wir geben so viel Geld aus ja
wir haben noch gar nicht so viel Geld
ich weiß nicht na klar drucken wir mal
das Geld aber das Geld ist doch gar
nicht da ich kann auch mir eine
druckermaschine nehmen und da drucke ich
einfach unterschreibe dann 100 Mark
Knopfdruck oder Virus gar nicht so läuft
es nicht aber im Endeffekt ich habe es
doch dann ich hätte es dann auch nicht
sie meinen die Schulden die die
Regierung ja machen immer mehr und der
wo kommt denn das hin und wer bezahlt
denn das zum Schluss und das ist doch
das und was kommt jetzt noch das kommt
der Gas jetzt kommt Strom wir müssen mit
allem sparen es ist es ist eine Sache
wir wissen gar nicht wo es wo der Zug
hingeht das ist das Problem
ja und alle haben eigentlich Angst vor
der Zukunft und das schlimmste ist dann
eigentlich und jetzt kommt die älteren
Leute die müssen irgendwo aufgefangen
werden und die fühlen sich wie
entscheidet Durchschnitt bei Ihnen auf
dem Campingplatz die jetzt dahin ziehen
also wir haben eine die ist 28 ist eine
der wenigen aber die ist Krankenpfleger
ja die hat sich jetzt in Heimen dort
angeschafft weil sie sagt ich brauche
keine Miete ich habe dann eben ein
Dauercampingplatz und kann dann mit
meinem Geld sie ist alleine es hat
Pflege hat Geld und das Geld ist ja nun
nicht gerade groß das Gehalt als
Pflegedienst also wir haben sagen wir
mal im Schnitt sagen wir mal ab 40 bis
ich habe sogar eine fast 90-jährigen da
also ja also das ist jetzt so in dem
Schnitt mit 90 Ehepaaren
älteres also die sind schon ja die Leben
auch dauerhaft dort die leben dann auch
dauerhaft dort ja das Gute ist ja
Politiker am Tisch hey Leute da frage
ich sie natürlich jetzt wieder haben wir
bald amerikanische Verhältnisse in
Deutschland das glaube ich in Amerika
gibt es ja diese trailerparks ist ja
ganz normal das glaube ich aber nicht
eigentlich ist es so theoretisch sollte
einmal eine Rente oder aber eben die
Grundversorgung und eben dann zusätzlich
gegebenenfalls noch Wohngeld ausreichend
für Menschen um einen menschenwürdiges
Dasein zu haben und auch Miete bezahlen
zu können
du hast man hat das Geld
das Wohngeld was was man dort bekommt
das ist an begrenzte Summe und du musst
eine Wohnung dann haben die so und so
viel Quadratmeter hat ja und jetzt geht
die nächste Frage wo sind denn die
Wohnung da stimme ich Ihnen völlig zu
also das ist natürlich eine Aufgabe das
ist das ist eine Herz sieht schwer was
zu finden das ist die Aufgabe die Städte
und Kommunen auch haben es ist eine der
zentralen Aufgaben das Schaffen von
Wohnraum und da bedarf es eben auch
verschiedene Segmente die bedient werden
müssen wir brauchen natürlich auch
dieses basissegment für Menschen die
eben am Existenzminimum leben müssen die
versuchen wir natürlich zu unterstützen
mit der Grundsicherung einerseits
Wohngeld andererseits aber natürlich in
solchen Zeiten wie jetzt wo gleichzeitig
so viele teurer wird ist gerade auch für
diese Menschen ist sehr schwierig mit
Energie mit Lebensmitteln allem drum und
dran wenn man am Ende noch
möglicherweise ein Auto auf ein Auto
angewiesen ist Treibstoffe werden teurer
Wartung wird teurer alles wird teuer und
da müssen wir einfach da müssen wir auch
als politiklösung anbie da bin ich
völlig mit ihnen konform aber dazu
gehört eben auch das wohnraumproblem zu
lösen und das tun die Städte und
Kommunen insbesondere Berlin momentan
viel zu wenig als nehmen sie auch als
Polizei nimmt die Polizei die
Existenzängste war der Menschen also
momentan kann ich das kann ich das so
nicht bestätigen
aber diese diese Situation in der wir
uns momentan befinden mit den erhöhten
Kraftstoffpreisen mit den exorbitant
hohen Mieten in den hochpreisregionen
ich nehme jetzt mal Berlin als Beispiel
stellen sich vor jemand wohnt auf dem
Land in der Uckermark in der
wunderschönen Uckermark wir sollten
etwas Werbung nachdem sie so gewundert
wirklich und kann sich in Berlin
schlichtweg keine Wohnung leisten ist
also darauf angewiesen zu pendeln jetzt
ist es nicht besonders leicht in dieser
wunderschönen Uckermark
mit öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln
auch zu den Zeiten wo oftmals ja auch
Menschen die in Schichten arbeiten
der wird jetzt bestraft mit den hohen
Spritpreisen also er kann sich keine
Wohnung leisten in Berlin unter die
junge Familie kann sich aber auch nicht
leisten zur Arbeit zu pendeln und noch
dramatischer wird wenn jetzt zum
Jahresende die die Nebenkostenabrechnung
von dem von dem Mietwohnung gekommen da
gehe ich mal davon aus da werden viele
schlichtweg vor dem Existenzminimum
stellen denn das was man sonst so an
monatlichen Abschlägen an Gas und Strom
und Wasser bezahlt und auch kalkuliert
logischerweise
der wird kommen und wenn das und wenn
das über 100% Steigerung ist dann könnte
ich mir vorstellen dass dann irgendwann
vor Weihnachten oder im nächsten
Frühjahr auch die Polizei da spüren wird
dass Menschen schlichtweg kein Geld mehr
haben aber irgendwie dort über die
Runden kommen müssen und das nennt man
dann im Drogen Million nimmt man das
Beschaffungskriminalität wir sind hier
gar nicht mehr so weit von entfernt wenn
sich da nicht beschleunigt was tut und
wichtig ist mir auch das genau
diejenigen Familien und auch
Alleinerziehenden die die
Geld verdienen die täglich zur Arbeit
gehen was davon spüren und nicht
diejenigen die eh schon die staatlichen
oder oder wenn diejenigen es nicht
merken die sowieso schon vom Staat
unterstützt werden weil sie Zuschüsse
bekommen zu ihren Heizkosten oder oder
oder zu ihr Nebenkosten dann könnte das
könnte das für für große Spannung in
unserem Land sorgen bin ich jetzt
vorsichtig
auf dem Campingplatz zu wohnen nicht
wirklich wenn es nicht anders geht ja
dann muss man halt in so einen Apfel
beißen ich würde es aber
vermeiden auf jeden Fall also wenn es
nach Möglichkeiten ja aber wenn es nicht
anders geht dann ist die finanzielle
Situation so schwierig ist dann dann
muss man das halt dann ist das halt so
ist besser als nichts als unter der
Brücke würde ich mal sagen ja und dann
zufrieren oder was auch unabhängig davon
dass der Campingplatz also keine
schlechte Sache ist auch gar nicht
schmieren also es ist zwar bestimmt
kleiner aber das soziale Umfeld ist dort
auf dem Campingplatz wesentlich dann ist
dann auch hier das Ding das eben der
nicht arbeitende oder der
Arbeitssuchende der kein Geld hat oder
der verarmte Rentner oder was wir ja
auch haben wir haben ja von von
Arbeitern Klempner Elektriker wir haben
studierte da die sind dann alles eine
Linie und jeder hilft sich gegeneinander
zusammen wenn ich mir überlege ich wurde
in der Stadt sein hätte ein Mietshaus
wurde in einem Mietshaus wohnen und
würde nebenan ein Haus haben wo eben
jemand Geld hat da geht derjenige aus
dem Mietshaus hundertprozentig nicht zu
dem Nachbarn von dem Haus hin und sagt
hilf mir mal aber dagegen auf dem
Campingplatz ist das alles einzeln
in der Wohnung oder diese dieses soziale
eben was eben dann trotzdem diese Halt
auf dem Campingplatz ist dann wesentlich
besser wie wenn ich dann zu Hause in
meiner Wohnung und dann mit meinen
Talern und so kann ich doch mal
woanders hingehen und wenigstens mal
mein Herz ausschütten und sagen oh mir
geht's heute nicht gut und die hören
auch alle zu also das ist also jetzt mit
finanziellen Mitteln werden sie nicht
unterstützt aber auf jeden Fall das
Zuhören ist unheimlich wichtig bei
vielen weil ich denke mal
Ende des Jahres werden sich einige
umgucken definitiv und ich habe wirklich
eigentlich schon Angst davor was so in
welche Richtung das dann geht also das
wird schon erschreckend werden und ich
sehe das wirklich jetzt bei uns auf den
Plätzen wie sich das in diese Richtung
entwickelt also das wird schon schlimm
wir hoffen mal dass die Panik nicht ganz
so sein muss wie wir sie aktuell haben
und es nicht ganz so schlimm wird ich
hoffe dass die Medien nicht ganz so viel
die sollen Lösungen finden die sollen
den Leuten vielleicht auch sagen was er
machen sollen aber aber die vielleicht
ist es jetzt auch gerade so dass selbst
die Politik nicht wissen was was du zu
tun haben oder so aber jetzt kommt ihm
das wird abgestellt ja wir drehen jetzt
einfach mal den gasalp an dann gibt es
irgendwelche Leute die dann die Politik
hat nicht den gashorn abgedreht das ist
richtig aber aber das ist so aber die
Lösung finden keiner so jeder sagt erst
sagen sie wir schaffen das alles ab weil
wir wollen ja der Natur wir wollen ja
für die Natur sein wir wollen ja
ordentlich sein und so wir wollen ja an
alles denken und dann jetzt ist auf
einmal alles wieder weil vielleicht kann
sie heute jemand aus der Runde
überzeugen der sogar eine Lösung
mitgebracht hat und das ist nämlich
FDP-Politiker ja so